- [Instructor] We're told
that Samara is setting up
an olive tasting
competition for a festival.
From 15 distinct varieties,
Samara will choose three
different olive oils
and blend them together.
A contestant will taste the blend
and try to identify which
three of the 15 varieties
were used to make it.
Assume that a contestant
can't taste any difference
and is randomly guessing.
What is the probability
that a contestant correctly guesses
which three varieties were used?
So pause this video and see
if you can think about that.
And if you can just come
up with the expression,
you don't have to compute it.
That is probably good enough,
at least for our purposes.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So we know several things here.
We have 15 distinct varieties
and we are choosing
three of those varieties.
And anytime we're talking
about probability and combinatorics,
it's always interesting to
say, "Does order matter?
Does it matter what order that Samara
is picking those three from the 15?"
It doesn't look like it matters.
It looks like we just have to think
about what three they are.
It doesn't matter what order
either she picked them in,
or the order in which the
contestant guesses them in.
And so if you think about the total number
of ways of picking three
things from a group of 15,
you could write that as 15, choose three.
Once again, this is
just shorthand notation
for how many combinations are there,
so you can pick three
things from a group of 15?
So some of you might
have been tempted to say,
"Hey, let me think
about permutations here.
And I have 15 things.
And from that, I wanna
figure out how many ways
can I pick three things that
actually has order mattering?"
But this would be the
situation where we're talking
about the contestant actually
having to maybe guess
in the same order in which the varieties
were originally blended,
or something like that,
but we're not doing that,
we just care about getting
the right three varieties.
So this will tell us
the total number of ways
that you can pick three out of 15.
And so what's the probability
that the contestant correctly guesses
which three varieties were used?
Well, the contestant is
going to be guessing one
out of the possible
number of scenarios here.
So the probability would be
one over 15, choose three.
And if you wanted to compute this,
this would be equal to one over,
now, how many ways can you
pick three things from 15?
And of course there is a formula here,
but I always like to reason through it.
Well, you could say, "All
right, if there's three slots,
there's 15 different varieties
that could've gone into that first slot,
and then there's 14 that could
go into that second slot,
and then there's 13 that can
go into that third slot."
But then we have to remember
that it doesn't matter
what order we pick them in.
So how many ways can you
rearrange three things?
Well, it would be three factorial,
or three times two times one.
So this would be the same thing
as three times two times one
over 15 times 14 times 13.
See, I can simplify this,
divide numerator and denominator by two,
divide numerator and denominator by three.
This is going to be equal
to one over 35 times 13.
This is going to be one over
350 plus 105, which is 455.
And we are done.